so the marketing world social media
world a lot of people talk about this
British Airways thing where somebody
bought Promoted Tweet to complain about
British Airways caught a lot of traction
tons of articles running about it as a
matter of fact someone do some editing
throw some of the logos of the people
that are writing about it here there's a
quote from one of the articles by CEO of
the social media agency saying with
someone with six followers who's on
Twitter and who makes a nasty tweet it's
completely irrelevant now tom is lost in
text so I don't want to flame on which
I'm not even bringing up who said that
or where it was said but it was a quote
and it's one that really drives to the
heart of why I want to make this video I
am completely stunned that for all the
talk of the new world this then the
other thing we continue to talk in
old-school terms of the absolute number
the scale of how many impressions right
the scale of how many followers which is
so irrelevant that statement is
ludicrous what if your six followers
happen to be sadly Johnny Tommy Jimmy
and Chris and you tweeted out that you
hate British Airways and one of those
six which are you relevant let me just
read again because it's very exciting
for me with someone who has six
followers on Twitter and who makes a
nasty tweet it seemed completely
irrelevant so I don't know how six human
beings are in relevant but it's a
separate story but what if one of those
six people happen to be Sally and she
retweets it now sally has 39 followers
still an irrelevant number based on this
guy's point of view what if one of those
39 people happen to be one of her
friends from college who happens to be a
showrunner on The Today Show what if
that happens dude what that happens and
then all of a sudden that showrunner
brings that tweet or awareness or
statement or comment or picture or
whatever it may be to those producers of
that show and then all of a sudden some
the today's show the next day or the USA
today newspaper or somewhere a bigger
magnitude and bigger scale that this
person believes is important the thought
that other human beings or low numbers
of those human beings are irrelevant is
ludicrous the absolute number doesn't
matter you can have a million followers
you can have a hundred followers one
proper tweet one proper statement can go
to other people and the word of mouth
plumbing that social networks are allows
everything that's go file you don't take
a viral you just need to go to the right
person you've got two followers they can
be Oprah and Obama and that matters this
absolute number thing is stupid
it's very stupid and we continue to keep
talking about that it's not irrelevant
every consumers word does matter because
word of mouth is now at scale and as
infrastructure to go somewhere and we
need to start thinking about that in a
very serious way because we completely
misunderstand it